Doug Peterson fearless how an underdog
becomes a champion and the coach himself
and author Doug Peterson here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you coach rich
I'm good and I felt that tap all the way
in New York there yes there you go
you know what that tap sounds that's
that's just you being on this show
number one bestseller here it comes
that's what I'm saying you know that's
what we do here as Dennis Green said we
crown people we crown as you did just a
couple of months ago in the Super Bowl
let me just before we get to the book
Doug let's get to last night what did
you what do you take out of a game like
that in Week three of a preseason coach
well yeah first of all I take away that
you know our defense is obviously in a
good spot right now they've played they
played well last night and and really
they for the most part of played pretty
well throughout preseason and and and
sometimes defenses are ahead of offenses
at this point but they're they're
playing extremely well special teams I
thought had a had a had a better night
last night you know our coverage units I
know we missed the one field goal and
and I still got a lot of confidence in
Jake but recovered coverage teams did a
really nice job last night and then
offensively you know I'm you know we're
just missing or missing too many pieces
right now you know we're missing guys
like Al Sean Jeffrey and Nelson Aguilar
and some of our top top playmakers and
Corey Clemente and JJ and you know
Darren Sproles so it's tough we're
playing a lot of young players over
there on that side of the ball and and
which is good for them they're getting a
lot of a lot of work and a lot of time
and you know getting some valuable
experience out there and and so that's
that's kind of kind of my takeaway I'd
love to have a little more you know a
little more you know fluidity on offense
but sometimes that's that's what you're
dealt is you go into these preseason
games well I'm gonna spare you the
carson wentz question that i'm sure
you're getting every single minute
you're having but that said I will I
will tweak it a little bit here because
when do you expect this doctor coach
owner quarterback I guess situation to
get together and make a decision when
you when you peg that coach well here I
I just think when whenever whenever we
get to that point I mean it's so you
know Carson's doing doing everything
he's asked to do you know obviously this
is this is a medical decision and and
time time is you know the the biggest
healer and the predictor of a lot of
things and and I want to make sure that
Carson is is is a hundred percent before
before we stick them out on the field
and before we make this decision and you
know put them back out there so I can't
tell you exactly when this is going to
be but hopefully hopefully it's in you
know in the near future
all right fearless how an underdog
becomes a champion Doug Peterson's new
book the coach and author himself here
on the Rich Eisen show what why'd you
decide to sit down write a book coach
well you know at first when the idea was
was brought to my attention I was a
little bit against doing a project you
know of this magnitude because it takes
a lot of time and it takes time away
from you know family and work and things
of that nature but then I looked at it
from the standpoint of you know I'm a
very private person my family and I and
we don't put our stuff out we're not on
Twitter's and instagrams and you know
any of the social media outlets so I
felt like this would be a great way to
sort of get my story out there and and
people could get a glimpse of kind of
Who I am just a little bit and and you
know my little bit of my life story
from you know sort of being an underdog
a backed-up you know role type
quarterback throughout my career and
then and then obviously you know through
through the Super Bowl last year so so
looking back on it I'm glad I did it
and I'm excited for it and you know
can't wait for people to read it and
tell me what they think well I mean one
of the stories that you told in the book
that certainly got a lot of ink this
week is you watching the AFC
Championship game in your I guess in
your office prior to the NFC
Championship game watching a knee being
taken by the Jaguars before the first
half against the Patriots saying quote
you've got to be kidding me now and how
mad that got you and saying if they lose
this game
this is why sure enough they would go on
and lose the game
did you hear Doug morones reaction you
know I I did it and I'll just say this I
mean it listen every everybody's
different a lot of respect for
Jacksonville they had a tremendous
season last year and coach Moroni and
what they what he's accomplished and
what he's done down there and you know
obviously established a fine football
team and you know it was just something
that I saw you know just just personally
and and it just it just struck me that
way and and you know obviously you know
I wanted to make sure that I was for the
Philadelphia Eagles doing the best and
and you know and that and that's that
was my reaction at the time but listen
this is too hard to win games in this
football league and and you know he
obviously has a great football team and
it just it just hit me hit me a certain
way at the time well I hate it most of
Americans honest with you coach you know
I mean and I know we've discussed and
it's been it's been well established
that you already had the Philly special
teed up maybe against for the Vikings
that very day and you didn't need it
because of the final score having that
in your back pocket
and using it against New England in the
Super Bowl did this moment in the AFC
Championship game can we draw a line
from point A to point B they're saying
that that inspired your coaching
decision on that day no no there is not
a there is not a line that connects
those two because two different
circumstances but you know it was a play
that we did have in and the the
conference championship didn't use it
and and Frank Reich and I'm a
coordinator at the time we said hey
let's carry this thing over in the Super
Bowl you never know when you might need
a play like that that might spark your
team or you know spark the defense
whatever or whatever might be and and
just so happened that we had the right
time the right situation the right
moment in that game to to pull out the
Philly special on a honest suggestion by
our by our starting quarterback at the
time and rice and it was just a you know
executed to perfection and give a lot of
credit to our players Doug Peterson here
on the Rich Eisen show and some of the
great
in the book involves some of your
friends and former teammates and in that
regard coach do you know is there
somebody designated that you have to
read this to Favre a good question
that's good because his wife will
probably have to read it to him though
or is there an audio version of this did
you do there's no audio there's no audio
version yet because I you know I would
have to take the audio version myself so
what is your favorite Favre story that I
guess you you could you could tell
everybody about right now coach you know
I think you know one of the biggest
things that you know Brett and I he
loves to hunt he loves the outdoors and
and just uh just to kind of I guess he
had a little light on on who he is and
how passionate he is about hunting he uh
he had tweaked his knee against I
believe it was though the Redskins in in
at Lambeau Field and you know we weren't
sure if he was gonna I actually had to
go in and play and finish the game when
and we won the game and and I go to see
him after the game and he's he's in the
training room he's got a knee brace on
and you know I'm thinking about man he
may be this is the end of the streak or
or whatever it might be I might have to
prepare and get ready to play the next
week and and in any of that but you know
he's sitting there asking me that he
goes hey yo you know be at my house at
you know 5:30 in the morning the next
day because we're going we're going
hunting and I'm like Brett there's no
way you're going hunting he said you got
a knee brace you can't walk in the woods
you can't climb a tree stand he says he
says it he said be at my house at 5:30
I says all right whatever so anyway go
home after the game and about six
o'clock he calls me 6:00 a.m. he calls
me and I'd like there's no way I blew
him off and he says where are you I
suede me war where am i I'm um I'm in
the bed he says we're going hunting you
know let's go and I said no we're not
and sure enough he had gone hunting and
he had climbed in a tree as a knee brace
on and you know and just sat in a tree
for for several hours that next morning
and I'm sitting there going Brett
you know what are you doing dude you
gotta need it this may not make it and
you're still climbing trees and he's
like a kid he said you know when when
you're passionate about hunting as I am
you're gonna go as often as you can so
that's just that's a little bit of who
he is and and what he how he comes
across and just just a good old boy that
he and I had a great relationship maybe
had a streak going right I know the
streak kept going well he played the
next week as I send you out the door
what is your evaluation of your your
current Super Bowl MVP quarterback based
off of last night there was a lot of
talk about what you said at halftime you
know and yeah and you know and and there
was there was a lot a lot of talk about
that and and listen I um I don't I don't
point the finger and then we're all in
this together
and that's the biggest thing that I
reiterated that after the game that it's
not about one person you know it's about
the team and and you know offensively I
was just disappointed in our performance
and you know we had the six possessions
in the first half and they ended in you
know two interceptions two fumbles a
strip sack safety in the or a sack
safety in the end zone and then a
turnover on downs and you know for a
team that that prides itself in scoring
points and execution and doing things
right we just we just didn't do that
last night and and so I was disappointed
in the entire offense and not just one
person so obviously the head coach and
the quarterback get a lot of the you
know a lot of the scrutiny and and you
know I guess we wouldn't have it any
other way but but it wasn't about boys
not about Nick or any other quarterbacks
it was about our offensive performance
coach enjoy the book tour best you can
and then we'll chat down the line and
certainly enjoy your opening night in a
couple of Thursday's yeah yeah looking
forward to that obviously getting at
home and and I opened up our season
against the Atlanta Falcons and good
football team coming into the link so
got to get ourselves ready to play
then with course and with Carson Wentz
starting right coach yeah
[Music]
this is not my first rodeo all right
Cody right take care good to see you
you got it the author of fearless so
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience